last night we saw the original team that
had issues way back when it feels like a
long time ago but it was week three when
the titans played the vikings that after
that game they were thrown into disarray
for a couple of weeks they actually
played better back then now that
everything's settled down the titans
have
stepped into a hole they're one in three
in their last four games and the
indianapolis colts by the identical
score i identical score to last thursday
night when the packers beat the 49ers
34-17 the colts
beat the titans 34-17
powered by
a second half where the colts
just grabbed
the titans buy the shirt collar and drag
them around wherever they wanted them to
go peter
what i thought was really interesting
about the game
two things really i mean frank reich
said
uh essentially um i am going to reprise
doug peterson 2017. when i was in
philadelphia i learned don't be afraid
you know go ahead go for it so they go
for it on five fourth downs last night
make it three times i think and the
other thing that interested me in this
game
is that
i think the depth of the roster
that chris ballard has built in
indianapolis is really showing up
because last night the best player for
the indianapolis colts was nahim hines
and you say well you know that's not
that much of a shock well
he was entering training camp at best
the third running back on this team
uh you know after they drafted jonathan
taylor
and i really thought coming into this
season
that jonathan taylor had a great shot to
be the offensive rookie of the year in
the nfl but what has happened
is that frank wright basically has
watched his games and has watched
first of all not just how elusive naheem
heinz is but how smart he is he's got a
little bit mike of le'veon bell in him
where he doesn't just charge into a hole
you see you know derrick henry can
charge into any hole he can be a bullet
in a china shop and get away with it
whereas naeem hines obviously a smaller
guy
has to pick and choose a little bit but
he's fast enough to get out on the edge
and to make it make some uh damaging
things happen i think he had 115 total
yards last night he was
a huge piece of the puzzle that won that
game
and a pair of touchdowns on his birthday
had a couple of touchdowns a few weeks
ago in a win over the detroit lions
here's frank wright after the game
talking about his unlikely star tailback
he just came out and he just he just had
fire in his eye i can't explain it
coach rathman came up to me on the
sideline he said nahim is on fire and
i said leave him in you know i said
maybe man we'll just give him a break
when he needs to break but let's
let's ride it um he was he came out
ready to play and he always does but
every now and then you know how it is
you're in the zone you got a little
extra juice and nahim had that today so
look great up there
you know that's the challenge of using
multiple running backs every once in a
while one of them is going to be for
whatever reason and maybe it was his
birthday but for whatever reason one of
them is going to be at a different level
than the others and you have to be
willing to pivot to that guy if your
staff senses it and it pays off it helps
you win the game peter
yeah and that's i'll tell you the one
thing about frank reich is a as a head
coach
is
you know some head coaches say this is
our philosophy this is what we're doing
and they don't seem very willing to
change it at all and i think coming into
this year what i said was right it was
going to be marlon mack jonathan taylor
with naiji mines as a change up back
but what has happened is especially
without mac
you know
frank reich and obviously tom rathman
they have to look for a combination that
keeps the running game strong
and the only reason i remember talking
to frank wright about this in the
off-season
you know when he was talking about
drafting a running back so high
he said we will run the ball
we will run the ball and i think that
became apparent last night when you just
kept thinking boy when are they going to
start hitting some home runs here and
they didn't need to
the one other thing i think about this
this game mike that is so interesting is
that almost in the blink of an eye
you know we both thought i'm sure
two three weeks ago even the tennessee
was winning this division
and tennessee still might win this
division but last night offense defense
and special teams tennessee special
teams
killed him last night another missed the
eighth miss field goal by stephen
gustowski the block punt the 12-yard
punt that's as bad a special teams night
as anybody's had in the nfl this year
yeah and that's really when the pendulum
swung sharply in the colts favor it was
that 27-yard shankopotamus as you would
call it from the punter that gave the
colts to short field they scored the
touchdown and then lightning strikes
with the block punt and a 17-13 lead by
the titans becomes a 27-17 deficit
in less than a minute of clock time
and that's that
for the tennessee titans that's it
so
uh it it it happens quickly sometimes
you know the titans get into these
grinded out grounded out grinded out
games but if you give up 14 points as
fast as they did last night it's almost
impossible to overcome
and uh that that that is going to make
it harder for the titans to reestablish
themselves i mean they were five and
every year
we see a team or two
that has that really hot start that
creates that buzz
and then all of a sudden it pops
and before you know it they're
scratching and clawing for a playoff
spot and
it feels like the titans in the afc
and the bears in the nfc
combined ten and one to start the season
now a combined
10 and wait the titans have six wins
right the titans are now six and three
titans are six and three yeah these damn
these damn bye weeks for some reason
they're messing me up more this year
than any other year how many games has a
team played but but the titans at six
and three and the bears at five and four
after starting five and oh and the bears
five and one we just we see that dynamic
and and i think as it begins to
disintegrate
it's hard to get it back you don't know
what you have to do to get back to where
you were
mike the one thing i would not have
expected let's go back to that houston
game
after the game last night i stayed up
and i did a little did a little bit of
math but on a few things but
what i find interesting
and and problematic quite frankly
uh for the titans
half of their season to me has been
totally unacceptable on defense over the
last five games including that win over
houston that was the you know the barn
burner the 42-36 game
you know half of that's half their
season now
they've allowed 20 29 points a game on
average
and that is not a mic variable team at
all and so that is one of the things
that has to change or they're going to
be a quick out in the playoffs i think
in january
yeah if they even get there and at this
current pace of losing three out of four
games they won't get there here's vrabel
after the game talking about what needs
to happen to get the titans back on
track
well here we go frable now
mike for abel everything's gonna have to
change when you don't play well and you
gotta coach better and gotta play better
that's really what it is jim and
um
that's what we'll have to do you know
what take a couple days off here get
healthy
take it take a good hard look at uh
you know what we did and what we're
doing
you know and continue to try to uh
to improve you know we got to play
complimentary football in all three
phases and that you know doesn't happen
for 60 minutes right now
yeah it really has gotten bad for the
tennessee titans and and
it's not that they were blown off the
field wire to wire i think that's what
makes it even worse the idea that
there's this
this possibility that it's going to
short circuit at any given moment and
and it's just gone and you can't get it
back because you don't have the offense
to come from behind now look they they
gave the steelers a run for their money
when they were down 27 to seven and they
made it very interesting but typically
this isn't an offense it's going to
score a ton of points and we saw what
happened last night when it was 27 to
17. i felt like you could shut off the
lights at that point so you know derek
henry's been neutralized after he had
such a great start to the season ryan
tannehill is still very good but he
doesn't have that aura of greatness
around him and and how much can an
offense really do to prop up a defense
peter that simply isn't getting it done
at some point it is going to manifest
itself in the performance of your
quarterback his numbers are going to
drop even though maybe his abilities
haven't changed at all he's just in
tougher spots it's a it's a harder game
to play if your defense is allowing so
many points and putting you in difficult
situations repeatedly
the one thing i've noticed with the
titans mike and ryan tannehill in recent
weeks um look the last two weeks he's a
48 passer which obviously
you would think is sort of fluky
uh and probably won't continue because
he's been so incredibly accurate uh in
the last year plus
but the other thing that bothers me
about their offense is that this has not
been an explosive offense the one stat
that the one commonly uh kept stat
yards per attempt which
over a one year period
ryan tannehill as of a couple of weeks
ago was number one in the nfl over the
prior 16 games
and the last like three games
he's been poor in that and so to me
i think even though i mean i love arthur
smith's play calling last night
especially the play calling on a little
jet sweep surprise thing where you
thought uh when they were at the one
that they were gonna bang derek henry in
there and then they just prance in for
an easy touchdown i think it was johnny
smith
i mean
those are the smart things that you can
do um as a play caller i think arthur
smith has got to start challenging teams
more
down the field than tennessee has in the
last two or three weeks
you know it was funny in the pregame
show jay glazer was touting arthur smith
as a potential candidate to be a head
coach elsewhere next year and these
narratives get locked in based on what
happens early in the season
to stay on that short list of people who
are mentioned as candidates and we know
that the owners listen to that and they
make their lists off of the names that
percolate through the media you got to
finish the year you got to keep it going
you got to get to the playoffs you've
got to be a guy that has that glow that
lasts more than just a month and a half
and the titans are fighting to keep any
semblance of glow
phillip rivers and the colts on the
other hand now six and three they've
been inconsistent throughout the course
of the year but here they are
technically atop the afc south because
they have the same record as the titans
they play again in just two weeks they
get a chance to sweep the titans at home
which will make it very difficult for
the titans to win the division here's
philip rivers on where they are and
where the indianapolis colts need to go
but it just felt like we were dialed in
and ready to go so this performance from
our team doesn't surprise any of us
but as we know and as you always hear me
say it's a it's a week-to-week league so
uh we can enjoy it for a little bit uh
get this mini by and then we got the
green bay packers coming and coming to
our place so this is just uh this this
was a big win but we know there's a long
way to go
that green bay colts game moved to 4 25
p.m eastern and for good reason both
teams doing extremely well and i got to
give the colts credit peter for not
letting sunday's loss to the ravens
hover over them they shrugged it off
because that was a game that it felt
like they were going to win
disappointing deflating and kudos to
frank wright to get his guys to reset
forget about it focus on the titans on a
short week on the road and get it done
and along the way philip rivers he had
over 300 passing yards last night well
it only took four to leapfrog dan marino
for fifth place all time on the career
passing yardage list and he's a dozen or
so
away
from catching mourinho on the all-time
passing touchdown list so there's the
top six right now
and
he's got a long way to go he's gonna
have to play
at least two more years to have a shot
at catching brett favre and i don't
think rivers is going to play at least
two more years
but to get ahead of dan marino is a hell
of an accomplishment because
you know that that's the guy when he
retired we thought he'd hold that record
for a lot longer than he did
yeah i remember going to the game uh
where mourinho
set the all-time passing yardage mark it
was uh
in miami whatever year it was but i'll
never forget after that game the
dolphins lost the game and uh their pr
guy harvey green
handed dan marino the st you know the
the the game book and just said you know
you might want to have this and the
dolphins lost mourinho took the game
book and he went
and he just tossed it aside
because to him
the thing with dan marino was and i'm
sure philip rivers
i would think he would say the same
thing
you know
numbers
what really are they i mean
this is nothing against philip rivers
but there aren't going to be a lot of
people who've watched
football their whole lives who are going
to say that philip rivers is better than
dan marino uh and and that doesn't
demean his talent diminish him in any
way as a player but to me dan marino is
one of the best 10 quarterbacks who ever
lived
and he played at a time if he played
today what would his numbers be
i don't know but they would be
incredibly gaudy and they would be a lot
more than whatever he was on that list
61 000 or whatever it is and that's why
sometimes when you hear those things you
just say okay
modern football you know but they
they're really not to me all that
meaningful
but doesn't that become at least one
extra little plank in the hall of fame
case for philip rivers like i'm kind of
lukewarm i'm sure it does because sure
in his own era he didn't really stand
out but if you finish top five in
touchdown passes and passing yardage all
time that that gives that that sense
that he belongs in canton a bit of a
boost
yeah there's no question about it but
what i am saying is that
you know in some ways mike
you know passing yardage totals
uh have become a little bit like pro
bowled births
you know do you really think about them
the way you used to
i know i don't when i go in and look and
sit in the hall of fame room the day
before the
uh the super bowl every year and people
start rattling off well he made such and
such pro bowls well if it's a guy who
played in the 60s or 70s i tend to give
it a little bit more credit today i just
think it's
jokey
because either you make the pro bowl and
you don't want to go anyway so now 105
people make the pro bowl every year
um or
you know i think the voting is
ridiculously flawed for the pro bowl and
but whatever
i do think
that you have to look at the one thing
that i respect a lot i respect longevity
and the fact is that philip rivers
especially if he leads this team to the
playoffs they win a game maybe two
you know i respect somebody having
longevity in the sport continuing to
play at a high level
and i think that'll hold him in good
stead when one day he his case is heard
for canton
can we put the graphic back up of the
current top six passing yardage leaders
in nfl history because i have one final
point i'd like to make
on that and as to your pro bowl point
peter this year we won't have a pro bowl
team ultimately with 100 players because
there's no game that's going to be
played it's just going to be the pro
bowl team announced look at these six
names these guys better enjoy where they
are on the list while they can because
it's just a matter of time before
patrick mahomes knocks all of them down
a peg from where they are he got to 10
000 yards faster than anyone in league
history he did it in 34 games so keep
playing as long as you can drew brees
and tom brady it's not going to matter
mahomes is eventually going to be the
guy at the top as long as his health
permits him to play as long as he
chooses to play although i have no
reason to think he won't choose to play
okay so
let's talk about the colts and titans a
little bit more before we take a break
the colts have the packers next and then
the titans again
hey you know
as i said the cults have been
inconsistent this year and even though
they've been inconsistent they've gotten
to six and three and they're right now
at the edge of that conversation of a
team that could be a problem in the
postseason maybe this year's version of
the titans that goes in to
a kansas city or a baltimore and pulls
off an upset in the divisional round
last year the colts beat the chiefs at
arrowhead stadium during the regular
season very different circumstances but
still the organization
is capable of going in there and going
toe to toe with the chiefs and they're
arguably better than they were at any
point last year
it's gonna get interesting for these
teams i i think both have the potential
clearly to get to the playoffs the
titans are the ones who need to to right
the ship the most but look at the
upcoming games they've got some good
teams on the schedule and they've got to
re-establish themselves quickly then the
next challenge comes when they go back
to baltimore where they did what they
did in the division around last year and
stunned the ravens and that actually may
work against them now because peter you
know john harbaugh and company
have been looking forward to the
opportunity to to get a little payback
on the titans for what they did to their
2019 season
yeah the benefit the titans are going to
have is that they will go into that game
significantly more rested and the ravens
will be back in baltimore at three
o'clock in the morning on uh sunday
night after playing
you know the sunday night game at new
england this week so as far as being
rested i think
you know the titans have an advantage
there but hey look it's not going to
help the titans if they're if they don't
play any better
we never talk about special teams really
very much mike but i think mike vrabel's
got a big decision to make i think he's
got to decide if he can live with the
inconsistency of stephen guskowski and i
think he's got to decide if he can live
with a punter
um who and look it certainly wasn't his
fault that the punt was blocked but
whose thoughts have to be swimming now
after
the shanked punt right before he got the
punt blocked so i would not be surprised
if the titans have a new punter and a
new kicker by the time they face the
ravens a week from sunday
i remember jimmy johnson's very strongly
held belief that special teams equate to
a full third of the game even though the
emphasis isn't supplied the way that it
is to offense and defense it swings
field position it creates points it
surrenders points and it can provide
that lightning strike that turns a
victory into a defeat like it did last
night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports